just this morning ross young finally
confirmed that the imac pro is not
coming at apple spring event so what i'm
gonna do in this video is give you guys
three different scenarios for what can
actually happen with this year's imac
pro launch first scenario i can see
apple completely renaming the larger 27
inch imac as the new imac pro and come
with m1 pro chip but then for the
upgrade options you'll get m1 max and
then most likely a new higher end chip
like either the m1 max duo or the new
mysterious 12 core chip that dylan
leaked last week the second scenario
there's actually going to be two
separate products revealed at different
price points a regular 27 inch imac and
then an imac pro just like it was in the
past the third scenario there's still a
good chance that we could get both
products because it would allow apple to
fill the price gap between the 24 inch
imac and the imac pro and then later on
in the summer apple will reveal the new
imac pro which comes with that new 12
core chip